the royal wedding was this weekend more
than 29 million Americans tuned in to
watch the wedding of Prince Harry and
Megan Marco you know I checked it out I
don't know about you I couldn't believe
a lot of the ads during the coverage had
references to the Royal Wedding in the
ad I thought that was really strange it
was really I mean it's a very smart move
by advertisers to sort of tie their
product into the Royal Wedding here's
just a few I saw having trouble staying
awake at this boring thing your parents
dragged you to red Bull now four kids
[Music]
Abreva when you want them to see your
finest not your purpose notice anything
different about this royal wedding we
got to get you all married
black people ah true love it's a rare
and precious thing but nothing lasts
forever hi I'm Tommy Grimm and when your
prince turns into a frog your fairy tale
wedding deserves a fairytale divorce
so-called criminis osseous will make
sure you get the castle and he gets the
moat
hello well yes that was my commercial
it's some turnout like this
sadly many do not conan weeknights on
TBS
you
you